okay let's talk about roe versus wade i
keep hearing about how this is a women's
issue i would never get an abortion i
don't believe in abortion why is this an
issue for me on top of that i also hear
that it affects low-income communities
however only eight percent of those
below the poverty line get an abortion
in their lifetime one out of three women
that make over forty seven thousand
dollars per year will get an abortion so
is this a lack of access to education
and an income issue or is it maybe a
poor decision issue on top of that 95 of
abortions are elective less than one
percent are in instances of rape or
incest so is it possible that again this
is just women making poor decisions now
let's talk about how abortions are
performed if you choose to get a
surgical abortion what happened they
pull off the limbs of the baby one by
one
crush the head and suck the baby out in
a vacuum the surgeon then has to put the
pieces of the baby together outside of
the womb to make sure he got all the
parts there is not conclusive evidence
that suggests that the baby cannot feel
pain in that stage of life this also
opens the door to eugenics aborting
children for having mental defects maybe
their gender may be their race next
let's break down planned parenthood
margaret sanger was the founder of
planned parenthood and she was a known
eugenicist 80 of planned parenthoods are
located within walking distance of
minority neighborhood margaret sanger
was a abrasive and she accomplished her
goal as the black population would be
double today if it weren't for abortion
her grandson was just interviewed in new
york on the street he was the former
head of the new york planned parenthood
and he goes out of his way
to talk about how this affects women of
color does that not give you the chills
or what for all of you trying to make
this a women's issue do you support
eugenics this was a lot i know but let
me know how you feel in the comments